Speaker 1: All right, we teased that this
might happen and it's happening. Beto O'Rourke,
former Democratic presidential candidate,
is running for governor in Texas against
Republican incumbent Greg Abbott. I think number
one, this is great. This is exciting. It would be
fantastic to remove Greg Abbott. Greg Abbott's
approval ratings have been sinking and sinking
and sinking in the context of his total
humiliating, farcical mishandling of COVID.
But can bet O'Rourke actually win in
Texas, particularly given some of the
things he said about guns in the past. I
hope the answer is yes, but I don't know.
Beto O'Rourke held the gubernatorial campaign
kickoff in Dallas, announced his candidacy Monday.
Three Republicans are also running for the
office now. The rally speech that he gave
was good. You know, he's he's he's a good speaker.
We can all all, considering he's excites people to
some degree, let's listen to a little bit of it.
Speaker 5: Greg Abbott chose not to expand
Medicaid would not take yes for an answer from
the federal government when they offered to pay
95 cents on the dollar for expanded health care
in Texas. We are the least insured state in the
country by a Texas model. There are many who
cannot see a doctor or fill a prescription
or take their child to a therapist than in any
other state in the Union in this community. We
still see people dying of diabetes a hundred years
after insulin was developed, which cost pennies
to distribute. Still, some people in Dallas
cannot afford to buy it and are dying of it.
The common flu. Curable cancers, these things
are taking our moms, our dads, our grandparents.
Speaker 1: So these are great talking points,
but are they the right talking points for Texas?
I don't know the answer. As FiveThirtyEight has
written about Texas voters have soured on Greg
Abbott, but that doesn't mean they'll vote for
Beto O'Rourke. Abbott is not as popular as he
once was. His disapproval has now climbed up close
to 50. His approval is below 45. But the question
that FiveThirtyEight asks is, what about voters
in looking at Abbott versus Beto O'Rourke? And
it looks OK for Beto O'Rourke, but he has similar
dislike numbers to Greg Abbott, and he's not even.
He's only now starting to run for something. He's
not the incumbent governor. That's potentially a
red flag. The point in favor of Greg Abbott,
quite frankly, is this horrible abortion law
that's been passed in Texas. I'm sorry. The point
in favor of better O'Rourke against Greg Abbott
is the abortion law that's been passed in Texas,
which we've discussed. That's certainly something
that could mobilize voters. But I have real
concerns because I imagine that this clip
is going to be played on repeat. This was when
Beto O'Rourke during the Democrat, one of the
Democratic presidential debates, was asked about
firearms. And this is my advice is always just
don't even talk about firearms in campaigns
because it really just mobilizes Republicans
to vote against you. But remember this?
Speaker 2: Are you proposing taking away
their guns and how would this work?
Speaker 5: I am. If it's a weapon
that was designed to kill people
Speaker 1: on a battlefield, right? So
that did well with a democratic crowd. But as I've
said before, that can really crush you in Texas.
So I'm excited about this. It would be amazing to
remove an incumbent Republican governor in Texas
and replace him with a Democratic challenger.
We're going to be following this race. We're
going to be talking about it a lot, helping and
hoping to inspire people to get mobilized their.
I just don't know if Beto O'Rourke is actually
the right candidate, and I'm not the only one
who has this concern, so we are going
to continue following that very closely